[Music]
on this Wednesday night Israel on the
brink of a fullscale invasion of Gaza as
Israeli forces mass at the
border scores of dead are buried and
more atrocities uncovered help for
stranded Canadians we have secured a
plane and a crew to bring Canadians home
those who want to get out and those who
vow to stay I am not getting on it I
stand with Israel plus news of another
can Ian who was killed she was murdered
by terrorists in her home just for being
Jewish life and death in Gaza the
humanitarian crisis from Israel's
Siege I talked to a doctor helping at
gaza's overburdened hospital within a
week the health system is going to
collapse plus how did the Hamas attack
happen the massive intelligence failure
in
Israel global national with Donna
freezen good evening and thanks for
joining us the people of Gaza have
endured multiple Israeli military
attacks over the years but this one is
unlike any other Israel's defense
minister is promising a war that will
change Gaza forever revenge for that
brutal surprise attack by Hamas
militants who stormed into Southern
Israel 5 days ago killing at least 1,200
Israelis parts of Gaza are already
flattened and this is just the opening
phase Israeli fighter jets have struck
450 Targets in Northern Gaza in 24 hours
leaving some streets unrecognizable more
than 1100 people including hundreds of
children have been killed and 5,000 are
wounded that's according to gaza's
health Ministry Israel's mil military
says hundreds of thousands of troops are
amassed near Gaza ready to execute the
mission they have been given prime
minister Benjamin Netanyahu who had
faced months of bitter political
protests before the brutal attack by
Hamas has now formed a Unity government
with the opposition the focus now is
according to Israel's defense minister
to wipe Hamas off the map and a warning
some details in this coverage are
disturbing Jeff simple has our top story
from Jerusalem tonight
Jeff Donna Israel's prime minister used
his strongest language yet in response
to the Hamas attack strongly hinting
that a ground assault on Gaza is
imminent
Israel's cemeteries are
jam-packed so many funerals some
happening side by side at the same
time they can't dig Graves fast
enough among those laid to rest an
Israeli Canadian Ben Mahi the
22-year-old from Vancouver moved to
Israel a few years ago his Canadian
parents and younger sister spoke in
Hebrew at the
funeral you were a brother who always
knew what to do she says I have no idea
what I will do without my big brother
Mahi was an Israeli soldier but he
wasn't killed on the
battlefield he was one of thousands
attending an overnight Music Festival on
Saturday when Hamas gunman started
firing into the crowd I'm still in shock
this Israeli Canadian was a close friend
of mahi it's horrible and the fact that
we're fighting against people who would
do those horrific horrific things just
shows how how hard we have to be on them
how how strong we have to be as a nation
we're fighting we're fighting for Ben 4
days after Hamas launched its attacks
Israeli authorities were still counting
the bodies in this Southern Israeli
community near Gaza even hardened
soldiers weren't prepared for what they
found it's something that I never saw in
my life entire families including babies
dead inside their homes it's not a war
it's not a
battlefield it's a
Massac in a late night address Israel's
prime minister said they found boys and
girls bound who were shot in the head
men and women burned alive young women
who were raped and slaughtered soldiers
who were beheaded this Israeli Canadian
originally from Toronto lives nearby we
have neighbor communities friends and
family that are close to
us
who lost dozens of their
members um women and children we spoke
on Zoom because his community just 2
kilomet from Gaza was still considered
too dangerous for us to enter Israel has
recaptured its territory but fears some
Hamas gunmen are still here in
hiding after a rocket struck this
Israeli Town emergency crews found Hamas
militants in the rubble Lawrence seelman
normally works inide cyber security but
is now overseeing his community's
security we're trying to prevent any
incursions inside our community
meanwhile Israel's military has called
up nearly half a million reservists
widely believed to be preparing for a
massive ground assault on Gaza in his
address Israel's prime minister said his
country is fighting an enemy worse than
Isis while his defense minister vowed to
wipe Hamas off the face of the Earth
Donna Jeff simple in Jerusalem thanks
Jeff Hamas has both a military and a
political wing it runs Gaza and right
now the more than 2 million Palestinians
who live there are in the crosshairs
Israel is launching steady rounds of air
strikes it has cut off power and
supplies of fresh water medicine and
food gaza's only Power Station has shut
down the UN agency operating in Gaza
says nine of its staff have been killed
International humanitarian law prohibits
the deliberate and indiscriminate
killing of civilians though Hamas has a
history of using civilians as human
shields in Gaza in the end it is
civilians who are caught in this
catastrophe here are some voices from
Gaza nowhere in Gaza is safe and this is
the general feeling of the entire
population not only myself I I had to
move my family for three times so far in
the last 24
hours talking about uh estimate
exceeding of 263,000 people uh uh
internally displaced within the G
strip
you can see the ER I I saw the ER it was
very very busy uh with patients uh
medical staff I mean every it's like
it's like a B cell everyone is
busy we reached Dr Hassan abua at shifa
hosal hpal the largest hospital in Gaza
he is a British Palestinian plastic and
reconstructive surgeon who flew from
London to
help doctor thank you for taking time to
speak to us under what are um extremely
difficult circumstances can you describe
what conditions at the hospital are like
right now I've heard you describe it as
a tsunami of people currently the
grounds of shifa Hospital are filled
with thousands of people who' sought
Refuge to try to escape from the bombing
and so the compound itself is has turned
into a bit of a a makeshift refugee camp
her fames huddled every corner uh of the
uh Hospital grounds uh and some of them
even in just the car park they parked
their cars and they're staying there
feeling that this is the only safe place
in Gaza the hospital itself which has a
bed capacity of around 700 is completely
full Beyond capacity we have patients
now wounded patients who are having to
uh sleep in the uh emergency department
Department um in terms of of supplies
the hospital is on its knee do you have
power do you have medical supplies well
power now is complete is completely
dependent on the generators which now
are depending on on the supply of diesel
that's been stopped as a result of of
the Complete Siege that was imposed then
you have this tsunami of wounded
4,500 in Just 4 days uh and that has
completely depleted the system of its
resources consumables medication uh
equipment all of these are in very short
supply I know you flew from London to
Gaza to help at the hospital doctor did
you expect conditions to be what they
are i' i' been to Gaza for its previous
Wars in 2009 and 12 and and the war in
the 2014 and 21 but this is much much
worse this is the ferocity of the
bombing the number of wounded in such a
short period just is larger than the
scale of anything that I'd seen and I
worked in Damascus and and in Yemen and
and in mosul and this is I mean
destructive capacity of the Israeli Army
means that the scale is beyond what
anything else that we've seen how do you
see this ending you know you see the
size of the catastrophe and you keep
reminding yourself this is just day five
five uh uh if this continues within a
week because of the siege because of the
number of wounded the health system is
going to collapse uh if there is a
continuation of the bombing is there's
an escalation in the in the form of a of
a land uh Invasion the consequences are
going to be
horrific and and you know um the
hospitals will collapse and and and you
know we're going to be looking at 10 of
thousands of wounded and and thousands
of killed Dr Hassan abua thank you for
speaking with us thank you the American
President Joe Biden said today Hamas has
brought evil to the world and he warned
Israel's prime minister to operate by
the rules of War it is really
important that
Israel with all the anger frustration
and just they not explain it
that
exist is that they operate by the rules
of War a US aircraft carrier strike
group is on route to the region and the
first plane carrying Us weapons has
landed at an Airbase in southern Israel
at least 22 US citizens are now known to
have been killed in the conflict at
least 17 more are unaccounted for
Canadian citizens are there too both in
Gaza and Israel Canada's foreign affairs
minister says the military will start
flying some of them home this week
Mackenzie gray is looking into the
Logistics of that it's the announcement
hundreds of worried Canadians were
waiting for we'll begin the assisted
departure of Canadians from Tel Aviv in
the coming Days by the end of the week
with the help of aircraft from the
Canadian Armed Forces to cc150 Polaris
the same planes the Prime Minister uses
will be on route to Tel Aviv as soon as
Thursday night to shuttle Canadian
citizens and their families to Athens
once in Greece an Air Canada crew will
bring evacu back home at their own cost
once this conflict started uh we
immediately started planning developing
options taking a look at the
possibilities of what support we could
provide support approximately a thousand
Canadians in the region have asked for
from the Federal Government after our
Canada canceled direct flights to
Montreal and
Toronto J Burke is in Israel for her
wedding and was scheduled to return back
to Canada on Saturday but that plan
altered during our interview this just
in breaking news our flight has been
from Saturday to Sunday if there's a
flight available to us sooner will we be
getting on it
150% cancellations and delays a common
occurrence for anyone trying to leave
from benan airport with only 53% of
scheduled flights leaving yesterday a
number likely to drop saying it's
suspended all flly T you pH till further
notice after British Airways pulled out
of Israel citing safety concerns forcing
this plane to take a uturn mid-flight
and head back to
London but landing in Gaza impossible
the airport closed for 20 years and left
in Ruins combined that with Israeli
bombardment of the main Crossing into
Egypt and Canadians in Gaza have only
one hope to get out should the United
Nations work on an evacuation we would
be working with them but senior
government officials told reporters
there have been no guarantees that
Israel will provide a humanitarian
Corridor leaving the approximately 70
Canadians who won out of Gaza cut off
from the rest of the world Donna all
right Mackenzie gray in Ottawa thank you
a third Canadian has been killed in
Israel coming up her story and what we
know about the other Canadians still
missing we now know a third Canadian was
killed when Hamas attacked Israel
33-year-old adiv vatal kapon had
Canadian and Israeli citizenship she
lived on a Cabots with her two young
children and her husband Tia isri has
her story and what we know about the the
other Canadians still missing adal klon
was with her two young Sons when they
came under attack in southern Israel her
children are miraculously home and safe
but she is not she was murdered by
terrorists in her home just for being
Jewish a spokesperson with the Jewish
Federation of Ottawa read a statement on
behalf of her family who's asking for
privacy vital Capon leaves behind a
husband a 4-year-old a 6-month-old and
extended family in Ottawa Global Affairs
says three other Canadians are missing
but won't reveal their identities
according to family winnipegger viven
silver was taken captive I will not
confirm whether Canada has any hostages
because I don't want to increase the
value and put their lives in danger but
the Israeli Ministry of Foreign Affairs
says there are Canadian hostages we have
a hostage situation in a foreign
environment that is also a very hostile
environment there's no place on Earth
that compares to to Gaza some of the
missing also have ties to Canada like C
faret lapid doe whose father and Uncle
were born in Regina suddenly she said
there's a vehicle approaching them and
she can't she can talk and afterwards we
haven't heard from
her the police detected her cell phone
at Gaza senior government officials say
Canada has sent a small small team of
negotiators to the region it's working
with our five eyes intelligence Partners
looking at every possible angle to try
to find the missing
Canadians teria isri Global News
Ottawa security breach ahead why Israeli
intelligence Services failed to prevent
the Hamas
[Music]
attack Israel is widely recognized as
having highly sophisticated intelligence
capability yet Hamas launched a brutal
surprise attack and killed hundreds
Redmond Shannon looks at what went wrong
for Israel and
why Donna the biggest failure for Israel
was not anticipating this attack in
advance Israeli Prime Minister Benjamin
Netanyahu has won many elections
campaigning on a Security First platform
yet this happened on his watch he has
dismissed a news report that Egypt had
repeatedly warned Israel that quote
something big was coming his biggest
Ally the US claims neither country knew
what was about to happen we did not see
anything that suggested an attack of
this type was going to unfold any more
than the Israelis
did Israel's preparedness could not have
been helped by the internal divisions
this year over proposed judicial reforms
hundreds of military reservists
threatened not to serve if laws were
passed Israel does however have one of
the world's most advanced intelligence
services but according to one Middle
East analyst I spoke with it may have
been a victim of its own past successes
you know there's seeing and then there's
perceiving there's dots and there's
connecting the dots and when I asked in
a senior Israeli military Source what
happened uh the day after the attack he
used the Hebrew word for light
anesthesia a kind of Twilight sleep um
they just were sort of lulled the second
failure for Israel was its poor response
on on the day an attack that started at
6:30 a.m. on a Jewish holiday with
thousands of missiles fired from Gaza
the militant wing of Hamas has since
released video apparently showing how
they disabled Automated machine gun
towers and crucially communication
Towers delaying Israel's response more
footage appears to show how they trained
fighters to fly over border walls and to
tear them down helping vehicles to to
pass through militants also attempted an
attack using boats those methods allowed
around 1500 militants to get into Israel
to start their killing and kidnapping
spree at military bases towns Israeli
agricultural communes known as kibuts
and the Supernova Music
Festival it was around 10:30 a.m. 4
hours after the attack began before
Israel's Air Force began bombing Gaza up
this is the extremist D-Day land sea and
air they were able to compartmentalize
and coordinate in a way that was
unexpected and surprise um you know
surprise was was to their advantage
Donna currently the number of Israelis
known to have been killed is more than
1,200 the Israeli Defense Forces have
publicly accepted that there were
serious intelligence failures but an
investigation will likely only happen
after Israel deems that this war against
Hamas has been won Donna all right
Redmond Shannon in London tonight thanks
next Israelis and Palestinians fearing
for their missing and Stranded loved
[Music]
ones entire families have been killed in
both Israel and Gaza innocent civilians
are too often caught in Conflict they
want no part of Eric Sorenson has the
stories of families on both sides of
this crisis waiting for word on their
loved
ones Gia Calderone in Tel Aviv and hany
Al shaf in Cairo their worlds couldn't
be more different but their stories are
the
same this says Gaia is her 12-year-old
brother arz being manhandled by Hamas
militants she recognizes him near their
home at least he wasn't bleeding she
says the hering him here um it was so
hard to watch her father her sister and
arz disappeared from their Kuts on
Saturday and she hasn't heard from them
since I'm freaking
out and just thinking about my family
honey Al sha is just as desperate for
his family his wife and six-month-old
daughter trapped in Gaza he heard from
his wife at a border crossing
but at that moment he says an Israeli
air strike turned them
back she called me carrying daughter
with a bag running he says calling me
asking for help telling him we're dying
for Al shaay and for Calderon Snippets
of loved ones clinging to
hope there are countless such stories
Queens University Professor ODed hakai
is luckier than some his sister and her
family escaped Hamas militants after
hiding for 36 hours they know dozens if
not hundreds of people who were murdered
um I myself also know quite a few people
who were uh murdered in the massacres it
takes an IM immense toll on on your
psyches I feel helpless said Al Shafi
the toll taken on him is unrelenting in
Tel Aviv Gia Calderon feels just as
helpless my sister and brother they that
I tried to protect them my whole life
and now I can't do it there are two
sides in a war but for Palestinians and
Israelis missing loved ones the emotions
are almost indistinguishable fearful
alone and simply hoping they will see
their families once more Eric senson
Global
News and that is global national for
this Wednesday I'm Donna freezen thanks
for watching we leave you tonight with
scenes from The Many funerals for the
victims of the violence in both Israel
and Gaza there is already so much grief
and this conflict is far from
over
[Music]